in this morning's ion money report a new
report shows that Americans retirement
savings they're not growing at the same
pace of stocks which are again hovering
around record highs the Center for
retirement research finds most workers
have a 401k and IRA balances that are
substantially below their potential over
the last decade the average 401k account
grew the balance grew about 124 percent
and during that same period the Dowell's
skyrocketed 214 percent big difference
between those two numbers CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger is
here tell us why this is happening why
are they keeping pace well there's our
minute counsel there's a few big
problems structurally because remember
the 401k it's pretty young it only came
into existence in the early 80s real
popular pickup not till the end of the
80s that means a lot of people who are
in their 60s there weren't saving in 401
KS for the first part of their career we
also don't have a universal standard for
saving for retirement it's not as if you
go to one company and it's the same
format for the next company many
companies don't offer 401ks or
retirement plans or they make it hard to
participate maybe have an eligibility
requirement or the retirement plan is
investing in the wrong things and that's
why they're not growing is not no it's
clearly about person participation and
the real issue is that we have a
participation problem that accounts for
the biggest lag but the other part which
is really our own self-inflicted wounds
we have something called leakage pay
attention here okay this is a little I
know don't thank you I never never good
this means that we can get to our
retirement accounts very easily whether
it's a withdrawal alone and we pull
money out and also we've got high fees
put it all together and we've got a
problem because people are not saving
enough for retirement or this hi Jill is
this a good time to invest in stocks or
not well here's the problem everyone
wants to try to figure out how to time
the market it's nearly impossible to do
it so the old saying is it's not timing
the market it's time in the market we
need people to participate it has to be
consistent that's how we close that gap
between performance and actual account
values well you were saying that women
are hit hard you were telling me in the
greenroom that women are
harder on this way well it's really
tough when you make less money than your
male counterparts you don't have enough
money to actually save or you can't save
as much but also when you're not saving
as much think about this you're not
earning enough on your own record for
Social Security that will actually have
you lag your male counterpart women live
longer and they do tend to need more
long-term care because they tend to get
sicker than men that's a rough go for
women we need people to pick it up we
need people to participate and we need
people please please people just 1% will
help I promise
thank you very much